Jake: Today, something very special happens.
It is the finale of the Sam and Niko channel 2016,
And in this episode,
One unlucky person will have to shave.
Will it be Ben or Brett?
I don't know but theres been a lot of feuding, theres been a lot of talk.
We're gonna do a beard off, the loser has to shave.
It's real, neither of them want to
but one of them will
the stakes are real,
the competition is fierce,
*dramatic hammer*
Alex: I'm the beard judge
I'm here to seperate the men from the boys
Jake: Alright, to determine who goes first,
we're going to do an arm wrestling competition
Jake: Oh, its fierce
Alex: It's very even
Jake: It's a dad match!
Jake: Brett's got the-
Jake: Brett's got the muscle but Ben's got the length
Brett: *struggling* shut up!
*misc yelling*
*nerf gun is force pulled by sheer muscle strength*
Nick: What are you workin' on Brett?
Brett: Aw, man just gettin the Darth Santa costume laid out for the shoot
Jake: You know how I played Darth Santa last year?
Brett: Yeah
Jake: Well, i'd like you to play it this year
*visible confusion*
Well this is a pretty big promotion for you, quite frankly
Jake: You're gonna look like a badass
Brett: Hell yeah, son!
I'd be down for that
Jake: Alright, i'll see ya
Brett: Okay. catch you later
Jake: Today we are shooting Darth Santa Strikes Back,
We're gonna have Kylo Ren team up with Darth Santa
And they're gonna go around and you know, do what they do best, which is destroy Christmas
for everyone else
I had Brett play Darth Santa today, and
i'm really happy that he's liking it because
I didnt wanna tell him that it really sucks being in the costume
but it seems like he's actually enjoying it which is great for me, great for him,
you know? Everyone wins.
Brett: Some rough stuff, son
some rough stuff
so much fun, i'm havin too much fun
*hype intensifies*
Brett: *still struggling* dude, your face is touchin' the table
Brett: I don't think this is either
Jake: Alright we have to give that one to Ben, lets go
Brett: WHAT?!
Alex: if that arm wrestling competition is any indication of how the rest of this is gonna go,
it's gonna be a dousey
Jake: a pinnacle of manhood has been to know where true north is at any given time
well here, we need to know where true west is
whoever is able to point to true west, wins
Jake: Ready? And...
3...
2...
1...
Point!
Jake: Stop!
Ben: ahh, fuck
Alex: point, Brett!
Brett: Good try, man
good try
Jake: #2, chopping wood
Whoever splits it more evenly down the middle wins
Since Brett won he can choose which piece of wood he wants to split
I don't know how this is gonna go, man
*brett enters metal gear rising mode*
*hype intensifies again*
Jake: Right down the middle, son!
Nick: Okay what's happening?
Jake: So i've been trying to think about how to make
this shot that we're doing nastier which
is Darth Vader and Kylo Ren putting coal
into Christmas gifts which is you know
pretty sinister, what makes it really
sinister is a live scorpion being
dropped into one of them.
Ollie c'mere buddy, you're gonna stand right here
Jake: It's not here right now
Jake: Brett. don't think about this right now
I know i'm trying to frame it up though first
if the scorpion accidentally falls
on the ground
I will handle it, okay? No one do anything
other than get out of its way
Jake: You see this?
Brett: I mean, yup
Jake: Just reach in there and pinch him by the tail
Okay? Try to do it fast
Jake: There, you got him. Hold him tight, hold him tight
don't panic, just hold him
Brett: Get your pinchers away from me, boy!
Jake: Alright, ready?
Do it
Nick: Oh, god
Brett: *slight panic*
Jake: Alright, everyone calm down
Do it, do it
Ben: One more
Ben: One more and then we got it
Alright, we got it
Jake: You're doin a great job
Brett: We can play it together
Jake: Nah
There can only be one Vader
Brett: I can wear it for like, 30 minutes and you could wear it for 3 hours, we'll just switch off son
Jake: I wouldn't wanna take that limelight from you, man
Brett: Nah you wouldn't be takin' it son, we'd be sharin
Jake: I wouldn't feel right about that
Nah, I think your doing great
and we're gonna keep you in it
Nick: Is that comfy?
Brett: The suit?
Nick: Yeah
Brett: No son it's covered in sweat, y'know
*mission failed*
Jake: Sparks fly!
Sparks fly!
That's a win for Brett
Jake: Game #3, the staring contest
Alex: Let's see if looks can really kill
Brett: I used to hold my eyes open son and just stare into their soul, son
Brett: You ready?
Jake: Either one to break face or blink, loses
Alex: Draw!
Jake: oh- got a blinker!
Brett: alright, I lost
Alex: Ben is the winner of this round
it's anyone's game at this point
Jake: Game #4, pushups
Whoever can do more in 1 minute, wins
Alex: If I see any shaky limbs i'm gonna chop those trees down
Jake: Go!
Jake: 20, Ben
That's 20 right there
Ben's burned out!
Ben's burned out, and 3...2...1...
just when you think Ben's getting close
Brett goes and does something like that
now Brett's up 3 for 1 but I've seen people
come back from this
Game #5, the classic turn and draw
whoever hits the other contestant first, wins
Brett: you got me in the elbow
Jake: 2 to Ben, 3 to Brett
Ben: Completely in control
Jake: Competition #6 is called 'shoot from the hip'
whoever hits closest to the center of the eyes, wins
Alex: the range is hot, fire when ready
Jake: Second shot!
Jake: Last shot!
Jake: Last shot, and thats why they call him last chance Waller
Alex: It did actually hit the targets face, which the other shot did not
sudden death
Jake: the seventh and final round, it is the lasso
they will try and lasso the other contestant and pull them off the mark, whoever does it first wins
Alex: lasso!
Jake: Whoever loses this has to shave
Jake: Judge called it!
Wren: Did Brett lose?
Jake: Well um, Brett, i'm sorry
Alex: Pretty painful
We can maybe find you a trimmer
Brett: Ben you can go sit down, son
Jake: What a gentleman, will he accept?
Brett: Good game, bro
Nick: What did he just say?
...and so he became Jake...
...destroyer of PayPal